finding happiness and being at peace
with yourself is it's a long journey as
we all know but i really got into a
great place and
i have an amazing husband
[Music]
i've noticed my goal
list when i start to make them are
a lot more life oriented than they ever
were you know what it used to just
really lean hard on career side
although she may be one of the world's
biggest country music stars miranda is
truly enjoying the simpler moments of
life as a wife it was actually a huge
blessing in our relationship we got to
spend some really good time together
like
not running crazy not on the road he
jumped right into this lifestyle grazing
the cover of people magazine miranda
opens up about the happiness she's found
in her life saying quote i just don't
give two about people's opinion of me my
marriage my music or anything else i
just care that i'm being me the country
star also credits her husband's support
saying he loves me for me it's a really
cool thing to have in my life at this
point in my life for more with miranda
go to peopletv.com i think that's also
what comes with having a husband who is
like very willing to just like go and do
and experience life and it's good for me
because normally when i'm off the road
i'm like kind of a homebody so i'm just
like trying to use my down time to
really experience life
[Music]